olá pessoal de bebidas a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer um mini
tripé província do zaire com vossa
comprou então uma câmera do gênio pra
fazer este projecto de cidade dutra e
gillett descartáveis e compramos aqui
trazia cinco e para isso eu peguei uma
libra em portugal também dava para
comprar 45 7 por um euro e no brasil e
não faz ideia mas transformando uma
libra real dá mais ou menos cinco reais
gillet descartável de tão baratas em
qualquer parte do mundo
esse projeto vai mudar bastante jeito
porque precisava de uma câmera para
filmar algumas partes de alguns
tutoriais episódio filmado perto pra
vocês verem os promenores então eu vou
usar esse tripé e em go pro filmar
alguns tutoriais ou parte da construtora
uma coisa pessoal e os vinhos falado de
reserva de níveis que tinham fazer uma
lista e já tenho 30 projetos mesmo
bacana e eu gostei - as idéias cultivo é
porque eu vou fazendo mistas mas não vou
fazê lo escolher todas as listas então
contenda ea procura das folhas recursos
projetos
juntei tudo ou te escrever e quando fui
ver tinha 30 projetos que ainda tem que
fazer mas é preciso ter mais algumas
idéias pelo menos mais uns 30 oc
então se vocês tiverem idéias do projeto
deixe na descrição que o fgts é uma
coisa pessoal esse projeto não é 100%
meu eu tive a idéia de usar a fazer uns
pezinhos do tripé num canal e que não
vou deixar o link na descrição é o canal
que faz mais ou menos o mesmo conteúdo
que eu seja tutoriais então seria bacana
você se vê lá e se inscrever em que o
canal do romã curso cair e terrestre ou
outra um pm por que o de vettel ele era
para usar mesmo aquelas câmeras normal
ou seja você volta mas eu alterei para
fazer o suporte para com o próprio e
vejo que vocês primeiro teste aqui em
caixa e se encaixar tem por bastante
cola em direito aqui deixamos esse cara
está parte usei a minha caneta 3d mas se
vocês não tiverem não tem problema
nenhum vocês podem usar fita ou então
podem usar aquelas massas em que você
expõe toda volta assim mais ou menos nós
temos cá e depois no final passou se uma
lixa que fica tudo bonitinho e se
quiserem pois ainda podem pintar
em termos de design ficou muito bonito
mesmo vocês podem ver que é muito
funcional e resistentes
vocês podem levantar deixar cair que era
boa
então é isso aí pessoal muito obrigada 3
tido eu espero que tenham gostado até a
próxima
e não esqueçam dar a vossa sugestão solo
e não é uma descrição dos comentários em
greve porque ele button